today mgm resorts takes a big leap
forward in sustainable energy
flipping the switch on a massive solar
field bianca holman is live with what
this means for
energy demands across the valley you're
looking very solar yourself this morning
bianca beautiful in yellow
oh thanks sherry and welcome back this
monday morning so it's no secret we know
these resorts
are massive it takes so much energy to
really
bring these structures to life for
example mandalay bay right here
and so mgm resorts hopes a new solar
array will take some of that demand off
the power grid and keep its resorts
running in a more sustainable way
so the new solar array is built on 640
acres
in the desert north of las vegas las
vegas it has 323 thousand solar panels
and provides enough energy to power 27
thousand homes
the 100 megawatt facility will
eventually power 36 thousand hotel rooms
and mgm's 13
strip properties including mandalay bay
bellagio the mirage and others
that's about 90 percent of mgm's total
power needs on any given day
mgm ceo bill hornbuckle has
has called the new solar project a big
step forward in the company's efforts to
be more environmentally sustainable
mgm resorts has other smaller solar
projects that include
solar panels that line the roof of the
mandalay bay casino
and the convention center now also
there's going to be a reveal later on
this morning mgm execs
government officials governor steve
sisolak has planned to be there in
other nevada state senators and so we
will have coverage
during our noon show reporting live from
the las vegas trip bianca holman 8 news
now